foreign
[Music]
ers Pedro amrams Irish tea Challenger
nasam's Leo Park Vladimir Putin thought
it would be a matter of a few hours that
in just a few days Ukraine would be
fully under his control according to his
plans the Russian army would Advance at
full speed and would occupy Keith within
a few days zielinski and his government
would abandon the capital the Ukrainian
Army would surrender and everything
would be ready for the Victory Parade
Putin would have his great military feat
and Ukraine would be back under the
thumb of the Russian motherland we also
found some parade uniforms there so they
expected to get to Kiev in two days and
then have a parade here so we can say
now that we have completely destroyed
their plans Alexander rusevich the
Deputy Chief of Staff of the command of
the ground forces of Ukraine however the
course of events could not have been
more different the ukrainians held out
Against All Odds International Aid
arrived on an unimaginable scale and the
Russian army turned out to have more
holes than a Swiss cheese the result Not
only was there no Victory Parade but one
year later the war rages on and Russia
has suffered an enormous number of
casualties both in terms of equipment
and as well as men
[Music]
according to existing estimates more
than 180 000 Russian soldiers were
killed or wounded during the first year
of the invasion alone we're talking
about an average of almost 500
casualties every day what's more in just
12 months of war the Russian army has
lost more generals and high-ranking
offices than in seven years in Syria or
than the Soviets did during their
10-year war in Afghanistan and to make
matters worse the casualties have hit
many of Russia's best trained units such
as the airborne troops and Naval
infantry but that is not even the end of
it check out this news item Russia
likely lost more than half its tanks in
Ukraine estimates sure we're talking
about more than 2 300 tanks in total
according to the count carried out by
British intelligence Russia could also
have lost more than 4 500 armored
vehicles of all types 63 aircraft 70
helicopters 12 Naval vessels and
hundreds of artillery systems and this
is only taking into account the losses
that are relatively well documented in
other words a real disaster
give you an idea despite all of its
attempts and to the astonishment of all
NATO armies Russia was not even able to
take kharkiv a city located only 50
kilometers that's around 30 miles from
its border and one of its main targets
during The Invasion yes so let's make no
mistake it is true that with his
missiles and artillery Putin is
destroying Ukraine cities like mariopol
severo donesque erpin popasana and
bakmut prove it but do you know what
despite all the losses suffered by the
Russian army Putin has not achieved a
single one of his main objectives
solemsky's government seems stronger
than ever the supposed unification of
the Slavic nation has been a resounding
failure Ukraine has not fallen and to
top it off its ties with the West are
much stronger and its Army is much
better armed
foreign
now does this all mean that Russian
dictator Vladimir Putin might be willing
to give in well it certainly doesn't
look like it
[Applause]
one year after the invasion according to
British defense secretary Ben Wallace
Russia currently has 97 of its combat
forces deployed in the Ukrainian War
despite this neither side seems to have
victory in its grasp neither the
Russians nor the ukrainians so the
question is how on Earth is this hell
going to end how can the war in Ukraine
be brought to a close what scenarios are
on the table for the major International
organizations well let's take a look
looking for the exit door
in early October 2021 a very important
meeting was held in the most important
office on the planet the Oval Office
among others the meeting was attended by
U.S President Joe Biden CIA director
William Burns White House National
Security advisor Jake Sullivan and the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff of
the Armed Forces General mark milley
what was the reason for the meeting well
basically to analyze the latest
intelligence information indicating that
Vladimir Putin might be about to invade
Ukraine we're not talking about
conjecture but about information the
risk was absolutely real we're talking
about the beginning of October 2021
almost five months before the kremlin's
troops finally launched themselves on
Ukraine at that meeting as confirmed by
Millie himself four lines of action were
agreed upon
first an armed conflict between Russia
and NATO had to be avoided at all costs
second in the event of War everything
possible should be done to contain it
within the geographical boundaries of
Ukraine third the strengthening and
cohesion of NATO was key the phone had
to be picked up as soon as possible and
fourth and possibly the key Point not
only of the meeting but of everything we
have experienced since Ukraine had to be
empowered and given the means to fight
yes visualpolitic community that was
none other than a meeting in which the
United States decided that this time it
would not stand in the shadows if Russia
infringed on Ukraine sovereignty and
freedom ukrainians would not be left to
their own devices that was the meeting
at which the strategy was set which then
gradually evolved and which along with
the solidarity of many European allies
and above all the tenacity endurance and
courage of the ukrainians have caused
Vladimir Putin to run into a huge War
one year ago
the world was bracing for the fall of
keys
well I just come from a visit to Keith
and I can report Keith Stands Strong
key stands proud
it stands tall and most important to
stands free
[Music]
remains free international allies have
supported Ukraine in total they have
committed more than 160 billion dollars
in military humanitarian and financial
aid a huge amount of resources that has
to be able to cover the needs of this
country until at least the end of 2023.
nobody thought the Russians would start
a medieval war in the 21st century this
conflict is going to change the face of
Europe as much as World War II did James
Rich Republican senator from Idaho and a
member of the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee but obviously while the facts
that Kiev is still free is great news
the war destruction and annihilation of
lives is still a terrible scenario so
the question is what are the ways out of
the war well here are the four ways the
war could be brought to an end of course
not all of them are equally desirable
any one of them starting with the first
one would be terrible for everyone
listen up
[Music]
one let Ukraine go
Putin was counting on the rest of the
world to do absolutely nothing that the
rest of the countries would stand idly
by and watch him impose his will on a
country that he himself does not
consider as an independent nation and
you know what in a way this could still
happen take for example the cases of
trump and his Entourage in the United
States or Le Pen in France who openly
speak out against helping Ukraine of
course let's not fool ourselves if
Ukraine Supply were to be cut off sooner
or later Ukraine would most likely end
up falling or at best negotiating a
ceasefire which would be a victory for
Putin and a disaster for Ukraine in fact
Western weariness remains one of
Vladimir Putin's greatest assets and
explains in large part why he is still
sticking to his plan and that is
precisely why Biden's trip to Kiev as a
clear manifestation of commitment was so
important abandoning Ukraine would mean
leaving ukrainians under the Yoke of
Moscow or in other words facing a lot of
repression and purges of all kinds the
hundreds of bodies that were in many
cases tortured from Booker and isium are
a good example but not only that at it
would also be catastrophic for the rest
of the world
think about it we would be telling all
the tyrants on the planet that not only
do they have a free pass to do as they
please when they please but also that
fate accompli and the politics of force
are the best guarantee of success now
apply that thinking to places like
Taiwan Korea and Moldova and you have a
winning formula for the worst of all
worlds if Putin wins in Ukraine the
message to him and other authoritarian
leaders will be that they can use Force
to get what they want
this
this with the world more dangerous and
us more vulnerable this is precisely why
this option is completely ruled out
President Putin's confronto was
something today that he didn't think was
possible a year ago
the democracies the world have grown
stronger
not weaker
but the autocrats of the world have
grown weaker not stronger this brings us
directly to the second possible outcome
two freeze the war
first the Russian offensive and then the
Ukrainian counter-offensives on the
first anniversary of the invasion the
war was already in a kind of lethargy at
least from a territorial point of view
the major clashes were limited to very
specific points such as bakmut the
Russians have sent many thousands of men
to reinforce their defenses entrenched
themselves and thus trying to defend the
conquered territory it is evident that
the casualties suffered by Russia have
been enormous but Ukraine has also
suffered a huge number of casualties
both military and civilian and although
it has received a lot of military
hardware it still does not seem enough
to clearly win the war if the Allies
maintain their support but reduce
deliveries the conflict could drag on
for years and then even freeze
completely what's more the passage of
time itself could favor such an exit
exhaustion fatigue loss of Social and
media attention or the fear of another
energy crisis could lead many countries
to end up looking for a convenient way
out that is to try to freeze the
conflict and in a sense get back to
normality
[Music]
even if Russia ends up launching an
offensive gains new territories and then
asks to reach a peace agreement it is
possible that many countries will put
pressure on Kiev to comply and you know
what Ukraine itself may have no choice
but to accept Russia's presence within
its territory and the permanent sense of
fear and frustration that goes with it
we keep repeating that Russia mustn't
win but what does that mean if the war
goes on for long enough with this
intensity Ukraine's losses will become
unbearable a senior French official told
the Wall Street Journal in addition this
would obviously mean much more pain and
much more waiting for ukrainians and it
is certainly not clear what future this
country would have could Ukraine really
be rebuilt and attract foreign capital
and business if the country technically
remains at War as part of its territory
overrun and the threat from Russia
remains it seems hard to imagine and of
course we cannot Overlook the fact that
the Ukrainian economy is in tatters and
its infrastructure is badly damaged in
other words that could spell Doom in the
medium term the inability for the
country to ever be viable besides
couldn't Russia resume its offensive in
a few years when Ukraine is weaker and
they have managed to re-establish part
of their military force even if it is
just by training recruits this is a real
risk
[Music]
in any case it would in a way be a
victory for Russia a less clear Victory
but ultimately a victory they would have
annexed much of Ukraine and in the end
the International Community would not
have done much Beyond its initial flurry
of action to prevent it Beijing is
watching closely to see the price Russia
appears or the reward it receives for
its aggression what's happening in
Europe today may happen in Asia tomorrow
Jen stolenberg NATO Secretary General
and take note because if the armed
Supply to Ukraine is not increased this
scenario is quite likely and perhaps the
best way out for Russia and perhaps also
for Vladimir Putin himself that is why
some allies such as Germany or France
two countries that are not particularly
comfortable with the war I'll leave it
to you to guess the reasons have been
convinced of another alternative the
third possibility to put an end to the
fighting
three thinking 2024
foreign
there are elections in Russia and that
is why Putin and his Entourage could be
the most interested in reaching a
solution to the conflict before that
date lest a military and economic
setback therefore call into question his
continuity in the top job in the Kremlin
that is if the war is not over many
Russian circles could push to get a
failed president out of the way in order
to place a new leader at the helm taking
advantage of what would technically be
the end of the Russian president's term
well to avoid such a scenario Putin
might be willing to negotiate and make
concessions that at least is what both
French president Emmanuel macron and
German Chancellor Olaf Schultz seem to
think but for all of this to be possible
Ukraine must be in a position to harm
Russia this requires the rapid delivery
of many more weapons leopards tanks well
that's the way it's going what we need
now is for Ukraine to launch a military
offensive that pushes back the Russian
front to open the way for a return to
negotiations Emmanuel macron president
of France and it might not even be
necessary to wait until 2024.
a Ukrainian offensive in the Southeast
capable of reaching the Sea of azov
recapturing the entire zaporizia area
and putting Crimea within artillery
range could be enough to force a
negotiation this is what we would call
The Big Bang action
now if a negotiated exit is reached can
we really trust Russia to keep its side
of the bargain well the truth is that
history tells us that we can't Ukraine
in fact is a good example don't forget
that Russia itself guaranteed in The
Budapest memorandum the security and
complete sovereignty of Ukraine
including Crimea in exchange for
Ukraine's surrender of its nuclear
weapons because remember that upon the
dissolution of the Soviet Union Ukraine
became the third most heavily
nuclear-armed country in the world
therefore in exchange for these possible
negotiations Western countries would
give Ukraine much more tangible security
enough military equipment to discourage
any further Russian aggression in the
future we're talking about modern
armored vehicles missiles an Air Force
and whatever else is necessary an
agreement with NATO could even be
considered and since we would be talking
about an agreed exit the country could
try to get back on track
in this way Ukraine could be shielded
and have a future in exchange for
certain concessions in an agreement that
although bad would be much more
acceptable than the previous scenario
this seems to be at least the perception
of the Paris Berlin tandem which
according to what they say today London
does not see as a bad thing either
what's more Ukraine would not run the
risk of what could happen in 2025 if
there were a change in the white house
and take note because as of today this
may be by far the most likely end to the
war of course there is still another
possible path one with many supporters
in Ukraine Poland the Baltic states and
also the United States of America what
am I talking about well we're going to
take a look right now
4 victory at any price
2023 started with very good news for
Ukraine we're talking about their
commitment to deliver dozens and dozens
hundreds of armored vehicles among other
equipment including modern tanks we are
talking Bradley's Strikers Martyrs amx10
Challenger 2 leopards Patriot batteries
etc etc etc if these deliveries are
sustained and increased over time the
course of the war could change
completely especially if more High Mars
more tanks and long-range missiles are
delivered let alone if they were
provided with more and better aircraft
and drones and let's see initially the
delivery of weapons had been very
restrained in order for example not to
have to accept a defeat against Russia
if Ukraine finally did not withstand the
challenge and what can I say it makes
perfect sense otherwise NATO would have
been badly damaged and the leadership of
the United States would have been called
into question of course the implications
for the rest of the world would have
been enormous now however things are
completely
[Music]
you see according to many reports the
Russian army may be exhausted and under
equipped which would explain why they
are having such a hard time pulling off
any offensive it is true that Russia has
sent many new men thanks to conscription
but it is also true that the combat
strength of these units does not seem
particularly high that is why a
succession of strong counter-attacks by
the Ukrainian Army could blow up the
Russian defense lines in other words
there may be a chance to go all out
defeat Russia and force its armies to
retreat and even leave Ukraine perhaps
with the sole exception of Crimea in
doing so the damage to the Putin regime
would be potentially irreparable and the
question is but what would it take to
achieve that much more extensive and
more determined Military Support of
course on the one hand this possibility
would put the nuclear risk back on the
table but we already told you about that
in a past video here on visualpolitik we
told you why mozgo was unlikely to
resort to that possibility basically
because it would gain nothing but
naturally the risk is still there
particularly because this scenario would
put the Russian leader in check
obviously losing a war against a much
smaller country with with far fewer
resources is not a good thing even more
so when military modernization and
making Russia a strong and great country
again was the Putin regime number one
priority for more than two decades
what's more if history tells us anything
it is that it is very difficult for a
regime to survive when it loses a war
you know what despite all the casualties
and all the pain suffered this is the
option with the most supporters right
now in Ukraine Ukraine
strative
mom
Donald
so there you have official politic
viewers these are the four possible
scenarios for us to see the Ukrainian
war end you could see that in any case
the best ways out seems to call for a
lot more weapons being delivered to the
Ukrainian government this is something
that almost everyone seems to have
understood even Olaf Shults himself so
now it's your turn which strategy do you
think is the most important to follow
which would you do if you were calling
the shots leave us your answers in the
comments and let's open up a debate and
now if you found this video interesting
don't forget to like And subscribe to
visualpolitik all the best see you next
time
foreign
[Music]